escribe 2.75 como fracción simplificada
y lo que haremos aquí es un ejercicio
que a mí me encanta porque terminaremos
con un número mixto es decir con enteros
y con fracciones me gusta esa mezcla
bueno yo estoy muy emocionada ya les
contaré por qué
tenemos aquí 12 y lo pongo en grande
en los enteros lo estoy colocando grande
porque es un entero está a la izquierda
del punto decimal
a este 2 le sumaremos
siete décimos
y le sumaremos
cinco centésimos
y esto con base en el valor posicional
que tiene cada uno
el 7 los decimos el 5 el docente hicimos
vamos a hacer la suma de estas dos
fracciones y lo primero que haremos es
buscar el común denominador en este caso
el 100 será nuestro común denominador ya
que se puede dividir entre 10 y entre
100 si nosotros vamos a pensar entonces
este 7 decimos en términos de centésimos
multiplicaremos tanto el numerador como
el denominador por 10
tendremos 7 por 10 70
10 por 10 100
de esta manera tendremos entonces
nuestro entero más
70 centésimos + 5 centésimos será igual
a 75 centésimos que de hecho es lo que
vemos aquí setenta y cinco centésimos
ahora ésta pudiera ser nuestra respuesta
final no realmente ya que no hemos
llegado a la fracción simplificada aún
tenemos aquí números con factores
comunes y este 75 y este 100 pueden ser
divididos entre 5 de entrada porque
tenemos un 5 al final y un 0 recuerden
que cuando terminamos una fracción en 5
y 0 significa que se puede dividir entre
5 pero si están acostumbrados a números
más grandes podrán ver que el factor
común que tenemos en estos dos es 25 así
es que si 75 lo dividimos entre 25
tendremos
y si 100 lo dividimos entre 25 tendremos
de tal manera que nuestra respuesta
simplificada será dos enteros
es cuartos con un poco más de práctica
más adelante ustedes van a poder ver un
número y decir esto es muy rápido tengo
un punto 75 eso significará tres cuartos
en este caso tenemos dos puntos 75 y
rápidamente se les vendrá a la mente que
eso es igual a dos enteros con tres
cuartos nos vemos en otro vídeo